so many different things that I want to
ask you about yeah a million I I never
write down like notes for a podcast this
is these are the notes that I have I
need to know okay are there any nice
parts of North Korea is there like an
aspen
uh there are more than 2 000 private
resorts for the Kings Island yeah in
these private Resorts they are all
pleasure Squad members waiting for him
to come visit
pleasure Squad the young girls in North
Korea the officials have to find the
youngers who look pretty and then they
when they turned a 16 or 17 they send
them to capture Pyongyang and train them
to become their three groups in
Pleasures called a satisfactory group is
where you perform in sex acts and the
other group is a happiness groups where
you learn how to massage the dictator or
like give him the in acupuncture like
that and the last group is a Dancer than
musicians
music a musicians yeah I thought he
liked magic
he doesn't like he likes the girls like
naked and dancing more than that yeah
yeah most guys like the naked girls more
for magic yeah I I really prefer David
Blinn yeah
wow okay now now okay so the the video
sometimes there are these videos you see
coming out of North Korea
can like and they make North Korea look
quite normal it doesn't look rich yeah
but it doesn't look as poverty-stricken
as people like you and others who have
gone to actually lived in North Korea
say what do you say about these videos
are they all fit like he'll bring up is
it all faked is it all orchestrated to
like trick the West like like do you
even recognize this place
I
is it's a capital of North Korea
yeah do you see that everything is a
propaganda Banner there's no ads all of
these oh there's no advertisements
nobody can like get a glory other than
dictator what does that say that first
time it's like uh like let's follow the
party's order with everything that we
have so are these places like propped up
by the regime to look nice or are there
some parts that are nicer in some parts
that are more impoverished so Pyongyang
is like a have you guys watched The
Hunger Games yeah so it's like North
Korea like that there's a capital and
there's other districts so the capital
looks nice
yeah because that's that's called the
heart of North Korea heart of the regime
is Pyongyang so that's why uh regime
says until we keep as long as you can
keep 10 alive which is in Pyongyang we
are not going to do anything until other
people die or from this starvation
because it's easy to do socialism and
you have less people oh that's why
they're starting us on purpose to let us
die because it's less people to take
care of not taking it easy control they
don't take care of us is it easy to
control US population right and also if
you're starving you have no energy to
fight back right right and they would be
worried about these other places coming
and obviously trying to create some sort
of Revolution yeah so within North Korea
we have enough room to travel to
Pyongyang oh I was going to ask you have
you ever been to Japan you've been
before my father arrested I've been once
because before your father is arrested
life was not he was a party member yeah
I had a relatively fine life for North
Korean standards really yeah interesting
which means I have like food three times
I'll close no shower no sewage no
bathroom I mean oh and that was good for
no refrigerator no
I was not dying from starvation yeah
because he was a party member he was I
mean six million of men are party
members so it's not that significant got
you guys it was a party member but still
yeah better than most of I guess middle
class people wow okay so they so that's
why they'll let foreigners go to
Pyongyang because it gives the
perception yeah like oh it's not as bad
as people say Disney words exactly but
the thing is even with him remember that
that uh Auto One Beer from Virginia Tech
the young man who got killed by the
Russians yes even as a tourist when you
go to North you cannot walk around
freely you're always accompanied
absolutely even in your hotel his crime
was going to be wrong for in his hotel
by himself without the guard I'm not
even pushing the floor yeah yeah I'm
saying you push the floor yeah I'm not
even was there an elevator yeah there
was in the hotel yes now where is where
is the money coming into North Korea in
order to prop up a city like that
so first source is coming from selling
weapons they sell the new career
strategy to Pakistan Syria those
countries how did how did North Korea
get a nuke they got the technology from
Soviet Union in the 60s 70s yeah and the
Soviets were propping them up before
China
through the China they were like using
North Korea as a buffer zone from South
Korea Japan and America right right
during the Cold War they kept North
Korea to build the nukes okay so they
built the news so they have the nukes
and that's their one what we would call
like a trump card yeah not actual Trump
but it's a term right a trump card where
it's just like if they didn't have the
nuke most people would probably just go
in there and you know do regime change
or something like that but the fact that
they have the nuke it's a very dangerous
proposition right right but even before
the news they would not go to anything
there so I don't think the people
interested in North Korea I don't think
the argument where there's no or is a
weird thing but just somehow I don't
think a world cared about human rights
that much even till this day that they
would like go in there and change the
region oh I wasn't talking about even
human rights I was talking about like
like for example if I'm China right do I
really want someone who I don't trust
who has nuclear weapons leading a
country or do I want to puppet
oh China is so grateful because North
Korea makes him look good
without North Korea yeah it's like when
a pretty girl has an ugly friend
right so you have to walk around with
the ugly friends so people go oh my God
she's ugly you don't even notice exactly
yeah not even a pretty girl like a
medium girl with an ugly friend yeah oh
cause as long as we're talking about
North Korea we're not talking about what
China is doing with the uyghurs yeah
it's not as bad nothing is only there
compared to what North Korea does right
oh wow so we're not gonna talk about
Chinese human rights of business as much
interesting that's the one reason why
they want them to be there also
everything is under Chinese control so
that's the other thing that I heard you
say so China bought I guess the mineral
rights and the Mining rights for all of
North Korea they like lent the lens for
300 years so basically it's theirs
caused by China yeah but not only that
like North has no oil right themselves
so they cannot I mean even they give
test nukes without battle so China got
that line for them because nobody in the
world can give them the oil oh that's
right because they're an embargo yeah so
if they wanted to they could just stop
spoilers just one week that regime
collapses so China's propping it up yeah
they don't let them even during the
pandemic they were like in the dark in
the black market they would give him the
whole the behind the scene New Times
actually covered that up yeah wow okay
that's interesting I thought that they
were just creating a buffer zone which
is quite which is quite common with
countries is you want a little bit of
like it's very it's similar to what's
happening right now with like a Russia
and like Ukraine yeah it's like you know
Ukraine didn't join up with uh what is
it called again
they didn't join up with NATO and then
Russia was like okay there's a buffer
right here we don't have Nate on the
doorstep we got something it might be
like neutral we don't know on the second
they talk about maybe joining up with
NATO it's like no we're in there we
can't do it but what you're saying is
interesting it's a publicity stunt
almost they're keeping this country
impoverished enabling the poverty so
people talk about the atrocities going
on there and so the atrocities going on
their country now my question is would
the world care it seems like we don't
care what China does to their people in
the same way we don't care what Saudi
Arabia does to Yemen like it seems like
as long as we're getting something from
them or we need something from them that
we just kind of look the other way with
the Civil Rights uh situation that's
what I try to change right now yeah to
make people care yeah because
I think people don't realize how
dangerous a threat is really right it's
what I'm afraid of is already there
North Korea is too big to fail their
news they have a capability attacking
actually Mainland America and while
you're getting so destroyed with each
other and fighting in fighting
everything the enemies are keep going
and their only goal is destroying
America that's North Korea's only goal
is destroying a man why do they hate us
so much
because this country stands up for
freedom and human rights individual
liberty and
all the things that North Koreans cannot
have our culture is very seductive and
it kind of erodes the ideology of this
totalitarian States yeah so as long as
there's a free Society exists it's a
threat to their ruling why people want
to be like us yeah escape to America we
don't escape to North Korea yeah that's
why North Korea regime and Chinese
regime understand that if they want to
make this unknown the dictatorships as a
norm in the world they need to destroy
democracy yes but even China has I think
uh relaxed their policy on capitalism
for sure right not when it comes to
control of the people you got okay so
bad but but even recently the people
protested the covid regulations and then
the government acquiesce the government
said okay fine you guys want to go out
there and get coveted go get some covet
it's like the first time in like 100
years yeah that this has happened where
the government basically
um relented relented yeah right I think
that was new about coffee like that
people really fed up in China yeah but
even to this say like we have people
trying to rescue North Koreans from
China yeah you cannot get on a bus
without your ID and government
authorization you cannot go to next town
without going through a checkpoint and
it became everything is isolated prison
within China like North Korea I also
think that and and this speaks to the
North Korea why it's so much more
difficult to do in North Korea I think
that like China has a much bigger middle
class and I think when you have a much
bigger middle class they have more power
in a revolution and North Korea does not
have that at all and we don't have zero
million oh wow question about covet did
did covet go through North Korea yeah it
did and a lot of people were infected a
lot and and how did it transmit into the
country do you know
speak China because they're the only
trading partner
pardons through trading that people
actually got sick nobody really knows
and but North Korea did have covered oh
interesting
how do you still get information of
what's going on in North Korea so that's
a big operation like literally so funny
when I talked to my North Korean uh
almost Brokers we have to talk about
like sugar and Candy it's all about like
you know what's how we try to rescue
some people so we in North Korea has no
internet they don't have international
service so we need a small grow a
Chinese phone through the border to
North Korean border then it's close
region so close they have the Chinese
reception so from America we call
Chinese number but the Border North
Korean agent they can accept the call
and sometimes the face timing but the
government nursing governments with gems
and watches and listens to all this
course so we need to go to clip the
mountain and the bike to the 32nd core
so on the bike in their hoodie and they
talk for 30 seconds and then about what
we will know like how things are going
like you know whatever you want to get
out of North Korea then they need to go
several miles and do another core
it takes so interesting act of Congress
to make a one phone call to North Korea
unbelievable yeah I'm not I'm not uh
familiar with the geography that much
but are there are there places where
they can access water
and then yeah and then like take the
ocean
some people do like in Cuba for example
that's how people obviously get here
they'll just make a boat you cannot do
dinosaurs because there's a police that
even the ocean is said by the guards the
entire ocean all countries of prison
camp entire country served by the regime
it is a prison camp entire thing is
so some people swim for 15 days to Japan
what literally a son and father Miracles
they swim in the freezing winter you
know like end of October that's North
Korea winter they somehow survived
escaped to Japan in South Korea yeah wow
wow and what are the other countries in
the region think about this do they talk
about it all are they concerned about it
all is it does it is Japan concerned
about what people in North Korea are
going through like I'm trying to they
have empathy for it or is it
um I don't know is there like a kind of
like lasting impasse where they kind of
look the other way so they do have a
sympathy Japanese but they're more
scared because whenever North Korea
tests nucleus it goes above them
right yeah they've already gone through
that once yes that's their real problem
they actually have that you can just
drop on them and anytime North Korea
shoots a missile now you also said South
Koreans look down on North Korea yeah
that was kind of surprising to me I
thought there would be a lot more
sympathy for what they have to go
through well can you talk about that I
think this is where Americans don't know
how other countries are so racist
how exceptional America is yeah in South
Korea they discriminate literally all
the people come from poor countries that
includes I'm so sorry India Philippines
Thailand Vietnam and North Korea too we
are very poor yeah and they look up to
people coming from the Western European
countries where white and and so yeah
even though we speak the same language
we have same genetics same history we're
same Korean they just discriminate us
because we are coming from a poor
country do they have any funny jokes
about you guys
oh my God I mean a lot of stereotypes
South Korea is a democracy and free
market so they need to come be
competitive yeah so they have a saying
about the Communists North Koreans don't
work hard as much as they do or they are
not as competitive they don't understand
capitalism
and then they are not trustworthy that's
trustworthy because we believe that like
all the propaganda so we can like
worship Kings right in front of camera
oh and they think like oh they don't
care like we have to do that to protect
our families there's this line from
camera and worshiping dictator like that
oh so they think you'll believe anything
yeah